pour en parler nous sommes avec pierre
le bret politologue spécialiste de
l'amérique latine bonsoir merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
depuis maintenant presque un an des
manifestations secouent le pays pour
dénoncer la faiblesse du système chilien
la mort d'un manifestant le 2 octobre a
ravivé les tensions
point de situation est-ce que c'est à
nouveau très tendue dans les rues de
santiago ces derniers jours il ya une
polarisation politique très extrême
sociales et politiques
mais finalement ce référendum du 25
octobre prochain
c'est la prise de responsabilité du
peuple chilien
face à un gouvernement qui a abandonné
les siennes en étant les auteurs
politique de la répression contre le
contre le peuple chilien qui dure depuis
le 18 octobre dernier
c'est à dire que depuis le début des
manifestations donc il ya bientôt un an
le gouvernement de sebastian pinera n'a
pas montré une réelle volonté de
réformer le pays c'est plutôt le peuple
chilien qui pousse à réformer le pays et
qui poussa ajustements à la avant un
référendum le 25 octobre prochain
mais il ya eu une violation systématique
des droits de l'homme depuis le 18
octobre dernier il faut se rappeler
quand même des décharges dans la rue au
mois de novembre dernier en 2019 il y a
eu selon le procureur général de la
république plus de 1000 plus de 8500
violations présumées des droits de
l'homme et la police et bien et bien
évidemment mise et devant les fêtes
finalement on a bien vu le manifestant
qui a été poussé par deux sur un pont
sur la rivière à santiago
voilà c'est inacceptable et je me
demande vraiment si la france ou des
pays comme la france sont capables de
condamner le venezuela il faudra en
faire de même avec le gouvernement
chilien
alors concernant
ce référendum aujourd'hui 75% des
chiliens welt un changement de
constitution
pour autant est-ce qu'un retournement de
situation est possible ou alors je vous
dirais les dés seront jetés
non moi je pense que je pense que
l'enjeu il sera après de vote
c'est à dire sur l'option que les chiens
vont choisir soit une constituante qui
sera justement avec qui sera composé
avec des personnalités issues de la
société civile soit une convention mixte
avec des parlementaires des
personnalités des partis politiques
apparemment l'option de la constituante
l'emporterait le 25 octobre
mais comme vous dites les dés sont jetés
je ne sais pas en tout cas je pense que
selon les sondages on est entre 75 et 85
% des chiliens et chiliennes qui serait
pour un changement de constitution parce
qu'il ya une grande fatigue face aux
inégalités d'une constitution issue de
la dictature vous l'avez très bien dit
dans votre note avant avant cette
intervention
donc je pense que voilà la fatigue des
chiliens et chiliennes vont finalement
se transparente et dans les urnes le
dans les semaines à venir
comment se déroule la campagne justement
en ce moment à ce qu'elle est elle est
très suivi par les chiliens dans ce
contexte un vous le disiez de violences
policières de manifestations en période
d'épidémie également est ce qu'elle est
très suivi par les chiliens cette
campagne je pense qu'elle est suivie et
pas seulement maintenant on a vu quand
même depuis pendant de confinement les
chiliens étaient tous à leur balcon avec
des cas tapé sur des casseroles
justement pour s'opposer à la politique
gouvernementale pour s'opposer à toute
la répression qui avait eu auparavant et
après une droite qui fait campagne voilà
une droite extrême qui fait campagne
pour le refus de changement de
constitution qui est une droite plutôt
pinochetiste
une gauche qui est quand même assez
divisés mais qui fait campagne également
dans les rues j'ai vu des images il n'y
a pas très longtemps dans les rues de
santiago dans les rues du pays pour la
l'option j'approuve est ce qu'il ya eu
des figures qui se sont qui sont sortis
un peu du lot ces derniers mois pendant
les manifestations
figure qui pourrait être portée par le
peuple chilien
oh oui il ya des figures le problème de
la gauche aujourd'hui c'est la division
comme dans beaucoup de pays
mais il ya des figures comme le maire de
recoleta la municipalité pas très loin
de la commune de santiago d'année leur
allouer il ya aussi mal quoi servent les
caisses ominami qui a fait pas mal
d'intervention justement pour condamner
la politique gouvernementale pour
condamner tout c'est la répression mais
voilà vous avez une gauche multipartite
et enfin il ya beaucoup de partis à
gauche et à droite ils sont plutôt ils
sont plutôt voilà il ya il ya moins de
division - de fragmentation alors il ya
aussi un set cette pandémie de convives
19 qui touche le monde entier est ce que
le scrutin est ce que cette épidémie
pour influencer le le scrutin mais il ya
il ya vraiment des préoccupations des
avis de saab ont moi je pense que c'est
ce qui est très important c'est que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
pour le voilà pour la tenir des gestes
barrières pour préparer la population à
ce type à ce type de vote dans un
contexte très particulier mais je pense
qu'il ya vraiment une
une envie de changement actuellement je
donc voilà je pense pas que ça ait un
effet démobilisateur de la société
chilienne pour le référendum de la fin
du mois alors pour conclure quel impact
ce scrutin pourrait avoir sur la classe
politique on en parlait un peu tout à
l'heure dans le cas où il y aurait un
changement de constitution est ce que
cela pourrait réellement apaisé les
tensions en cours dans le pays
à partir du moment où il y aura un
vraiment un réel débat sur qu'est ce que
nous voulons dans la constitution
dans ce nouveau texte constitutionnel
voilà c'est une chance et une
opportunité même des artistes disait
l'autre jour que c'était quelque chose
de match
parce qu'il n'y avait pas eu cette
opportunité là lors de la transition à
la démocratie inachevée finalement en
1990 voilà c'est une opportunité je
pense que les chiliens et chiliennes on
a envie pour sortir de cette injustice
sociale et pour briser aussi un système
néolibéral qui n'a fait que reproduire
des inégalités l'éducation privée le
système de retraite par capelli par
capitalisation
donc voilà il ya vraiment des enjeux
mais voilà c'est un premier pas le
processus assez long parce que c'est un
référendum donc fin octobre ensuite pour
mois d'avril prochain seront choisis les
membres de la constituante
et voilà donc ces voix là il y aura de
nombreux débats mais la question c'est
est-ce que le gouvernement chilien va
arrêter la répression
merci beaucoup pierre le bret pour votre
éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue
spécialiste de l'amérique latine